joining me now former governor of
Arkansas and Fox News contributor Mike
Huckabee and Harvard Law Professor
Emeritus and author of the introduction
for the Muller report the final report
of the special counsel into Donald Trump
Russia collusion Alan Dershowitz all
right professor what do you make of bars
a response look like he was at a hunting
lodge there - Bob Muller well he was
100% right Muller should have come to a
conclusion I think if he had come to a
conclusion it would have been there was
no obstruction of justice but he was
probably pressured by his staff members
not to come to that conclusion he should
have come to that conclusion and I think
the only thing Barr should have said
that he didn't say is that there should
no longer ever be any special counsel
the Muller investigation puts the final
nail in the coffin of special counsel
special prosecutors the Attorney General
could do this himself there are staff
people there are civil servants there
are full-time line prosecutors
everything that was done here could be
done by them when the special prosecutor
the special counsel in this case says I
couldn't have indicted the president
anyway according to the Constitution
then what was his investigation all
about as judge Ellis pointed out in the
manna 4 case they weren't interested in
metaphor they were interested in
squeezing metaphor so that he could sing
maybe even compose against President
Trump and it turned out there was
nothing against President Trump there
was no illegal collusion there was no
collusion of any kind with the Russians
and the investigation should have ended
the day that decision was made but it
continued on and on and on with
collateral crimes many of which were not
even committed and others of which if
they were committed could have been
easily prosecuted by ordinary
prosecutors so I think of seeing the
death knell of the special counsels law
oh no it's I I couldn't agree more that
performance yesterday by Muller I got
into a big row with our favor one of our
favorites all Eisenberg last night
because he thought oh well he it was it
was fine for him to come out and make
that statement yesterday that
nine-minute statement you know he didn't
agree with everything but that was fine
but governor Huckabee I think that
statement in and of itself was an
indication as to why this
special counsel a statute provision the
way it goes has got to be just done away
with just do rut line prosecutions but
these special counsels are always
opening the door to you know to
corruption or de bias or to concern
about bias I don't think any good comes
of it I really don't well I couldn't
agree more with professor Dershowitz who
by the way is simply brilliant and one
of the things that I have admired most
about him is that he is an admitted
liberal and someone who voted for
Hillary but he's played this as a matter
of the rule of law and an issue of civil
liberties which is what we should want
from every single attorney and certainly
from every law professor in the country
and for that I offer my sincere
appreciation to Alan Dershowitz here's a
baby contra de contrast between Barr and
Muller Muller comes out and speaks for
nine and a half minutes does not take a
single question Barr on the other hand
sits down in an interview and takes
questions there is a huge difference in
somebody who simply comes out and says
I'm not going to say anything other than
what's in the report but I'm gonna toss
some red meat over to the Democrats in
Congress versus the Attorney General who
says sure I'll take your questions I got
nothing to fear and nothing to hide keep
in mind that contrast yeah I think the
other thing that beau the other thing
that Barr was right about is it is not
the proper role of Special Counsel to
serve as an investigator for Congress he
should not have said yesterday two of
the things he said number one when he
said that if the evidence had clearly
showed he was innocent we would have
said so that's not what a prosecutor's
and say that's what Comey said when he
condemned Hillary Clinton and second he
said well there's another branch of
government that should be doing that let
the other branch of the government do
the investigation you're not the
handmaiden they shouldn't be anything
anything
we said too little in the report he said
too little in the report cuz he didn't
come to the conclusion and then he said
too much after the report everything
he's done since that report came out has
been wrong the report itself and young
what he said the other day I hope we
will never hear any more from special
counsel special prosecutors or special
anybody else they do more harm than good
and they they upset the rule of law in
the Constitution criminalizing politics
we've talked about it before and
gentlemen I got to point this out House
Democrats now have been ramping up their
campaign to get special counsel Muller
to testify publicly let's watch Bob
Muller has one more service to provide
the country much as he appears reluctant
to do so and that is he really should
testify before the Congress he doesn't
get to decide whether or not he
testifies before the American people and
he doesn't get to decide which questions
he can talk about I think it's likely
that special counsel mother will return
I mean mother could not have been more
clear that that's it for him I mean he
looked like he was passing a kidney
stone in that nine minutes okay he did
not look happy to be there the governor
should he testify though and whom would
that benefit I think it would benefit
the truth and III just would think that
for the first time we might get our
money's worth out of the 35 million that
we spent pop some popcorn and sit and
listen to people ask Bob Muller why did
he pick the people that he did to serve
on that staff who were Clinton donors
was there any balance was there any
consideration to try to get people who
were completely independent of a
political bias there's some questions
that would I know be delightful to watch
and I don't think Democrats really want
Bob Muller to show up and testify under
oath because it probably will not be
good for them I want to play something
for both of you from the Obamas longtime
confidant trusted advisor Valerie
Jarrett who was being interviewed I
think it was on I don't know what it was
on she's being interviewed on Sirius
radio and this is again a
about is there a double standard here
Trump might not get impeached but would
Obama have been impeached if he had done
the same things watch if President Obama
had done half of the things and said
half of the things that President Trump
is saying even you know as recently as
this morning would he have been
impeached and how long do you think it
would have taken about a nanosecond
standards have slipped dramatically and
there's no earthly way President Obama
could have gotten away with any of this
well I think a lot of people would say
the Brahma folks might have gotten away
with a lot during the time of the Obama
administration whether it's faster
furious or the IRS or trailing reporters
or now the FISA abuses but professor
Dershowitz your thoughts on the Obamas I
mean she's kind of alter ego of the
Obamas what do you think about that well
I know Valerie Jarrett she's a very
decent person I work with her and I met
with her on numerous occasions during
the Obama administration of course Obama
never would have been impeached Kison
Pietschmann is improper and I think the
Democrats would have realized and the
Republicans are realized
you don't just impeach on Maxine Waters
ground Maxine water says the grounds for
impeachment are whatever Congress says
it is that makes Congress above the law
because the Constitution specifies high
crimes and misdemeanors in other words
there must be high crimes to impeach and
if President Obama had done what
President Trump is alleged to have done
there'd be no high crime so there
wouldn't have been impeachment there
wouldn't have been talk of impeachment
this is a clear attempt to violate the
Constitution in the interests of one
party and if the Hillary Clinton had
been president they were trying to
impeach her for non impeachable offenses
I'd be making the same arguments the
only differences they'd build a statue
to me on Martha's Vineyard and they'd be
inviting me to every possible dinner
party because I'd be defending their
champion Hillary Clinton but I don't
care whose party is being affected I
will always stay COBOL objectively and
neutrally and read the Constitution the
way it was written by the framers all
right well
Lichtman the political historian who
successfully
he's predicted the last nine presidents
I think including Trump's 2016 victory
he explained why most Democrats today
are pushing for impeachment let's watch
trump is it in 2020 unless what unless
the democrats grow a spine and be their
constitutional duty and move into an
impeachment inquiry and i think the
evidence will show ultimately an
impeachment governor so the only way he
says that
they can beat Trump is to buy him
basically by impeaching him well first
of all only 29% of the American people
think impeachment is appropriate but
even if they think impeachment is a
wonderful idea then I would say to them
go for it knock yourselves out put the
evidence out there if you honestly
believe that the results of the election
should be overturned by impeachment not
the next election then go ahead and have
the guts to do it and see what happens
it's going to be a disaster for the
Democrats and it will ensure the
re-election of President Trump in 2020
and also the case would get to the
Supreme Court very likely if the
Congress adopted the Maxine Waters
approach and put themselves above the
law and tried to impeach any president
without evidence of high crimes and
misdemeanors the Supreme Court might
very well have jurisdiction to decide
that case two former justices said that
in concurring and dissenting opinions
and I suspect there might be a majority
today in the Supreme Court if you had an
overt attempt to subordinate the
Constitution subvert the Constitution
and use the impeachment power as a way
of reversing an election that's not what
the framers had in mind it explicitly
that concern that is how would it get to
the Supreme Supreme Court though how
would it ever get well if the president
were to be impeached
his lawyers would bring a case to the
Supreme Court seeking dismissal of the
indictment essentially dismissal of the
impeachment remember also
they decide it's a political question
though you think John Roberts and these
guys are gonna want to get a ball the
main questions they but I'm not worried
that John Rother Constitution liberals
would say that that's I'm worried about
that well remember that John Roberts
presides over the trial in the Senate
and if I have the lawyer for the
president the first motion I would make
would be to the Chief Justice
saying this impeachment has to be
dismissed because it doesn't follow the
terms of the Constitution it's not a
political question when you're asking
justices of the Supreme Court to apply
the Constitution goes back to Marbury
vs. Madison when Congress acts in
violation of the Constitution the
Supreme Court has ultimate arbiter this
is an unbelievable scenario even a
contemplate both of you or phenomenal to
try to analyze it for us tonight thank
you so much and is that your kind words